pierre côté accompagne sa mère atteinte
d'alzheimer dans la maison familiale
pour un autre voyage dans ta j'ai pas
voulu abandonner ma mère dans cette
espèce de maladie cruelle non froide et
gallas j'ai décidé de jumper et quel but
de la compagnie en essayant de
transformer sa vie tous les jours depuis
deux mois il repasse avec elle en boucle
les meilleurs moments de sa vie
la boucle est importante le look est
fondamentale à ce stade-ci de la vie de
ces gens là c'est que tu ne veux pas
avoir à subir dans ton domaine des
choses qui n'intéressent pas dont tu
t'accroches choisi quelque chose puis tu
loupes
c'est ce qu'il appelle des sessions de
plaisir dirigisme besoins de base d'ici
ce qui qui est avec toi sur la photo
pour y arriver tout est mis à profit des
photos prises par sa mère
un journal qu'elle a écrit ses chansons
préférées et des archives
les possibilités sont infinies pour le
réalisateur ce qui m'allume c'est que je
sais que ma création
voith au service du bonheur de la
qualité de vie du plaisir de ma mère
un bien-être et un bonheur dont il
profite lui aussi à travers ces moments
passés avec sa marque comme toute
relation dead
ça fait du bien autant à la personne
aidée que la personne aidante
c'est bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aussi pascal langlois radio commande
d'un paquebot